Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
thor 4 love and thunder video they just announced
that matt damon was going to be in the movie so
i'll explain what's going on with him they also
announced that jamie alexander's sith is coming
back for the movie as well and all of you have
wondered what happened to sif after thor ragnarok
because we haven't seen her in the mcu since then
so i'll explain why they're important for the
gore of the god butcher's storyline in the movie
and why they're important to the overall plot of
the film but if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i'm doing new
Wandavision weekly episodes we're going to have
falcon and winter soldiers soon there's so much
stuff we're going to have new marvel episodes
almost every single week this year the loki series
is going to start airing episodes in may as well
and we gotta confirm loki season two i'll explain
how that's going to weave through the plot of thor
for love and thunder as well because obviously
tom hiddleston's loki will also be in thor four
but you hear that matt damon's going to be in the
movie and you're like wait what matt damon what's
he doing in this film it makes more sense when
you think about thor ragnarok in the gore of the
godbutcher storyline matt damon played a version
of loki during that fake play that was parodying
the events of thor the dark world it was basically
marvel making fun of themselves for thor the dark
world some of you will probably recognize chris
hemsworth's real life brother luke hemsworth he's
the one that's playing thor and sam neil was
playing odin the first time i saw that movie
i couldn't believe they did something like that it
was hilarious but the reasons why they're bringing
matt damon back or why they would bring him back
because he's a really big actor and he's normally
really expensive so obviously it's probably not
for a really huge role but this person playing
fake loki is an asgardian themselves so he'd be
living in new asgard during the events of thor 4
anyway he'd just be walking around and gore the
godbutcher's whole thing is butchering all the
gods of the marvel cinematic universe not just
people like thor because he showed up in the
thor comics first he goes around the universe
butchering all kinds of lesser and greater gods
of all different planets and in the marvel comics
there are gods for almost every concept that you
can think of the god bomb that he forces thor
to help create in the comics he forced the god
of bombs to design it for him that's right there
is a god of bombs in the marvel comics because he
wanted to do his own version of a thanos infinity
gauntlet snap except he only wanted to target gods
so early theory they're probably only bringing
matt damon back so that gore can show up and kill
him at the beginning of the movie thinking that
he's really a god or because he's pretending to
be loki or boasting about being loki gore himself
wouldn't know the difference or care he never met
the real loki before so he doesn't know what he
looks like so everyone press f in the chat to
pay respects to fake loki sorry about that thing
with the tesseract i just couldn't help myself
i know i'm a trickster yes so mischievous
but obviously he's not the only loki in the
movie this is a multiverse story during marvel
phase 4 and thor 4 comes out right after doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness in the schedule
here and we're getting loki season 1 this may
this version of loki from avengers end game
is a new loki he's not the same loki that died
during avengers infinity war he'll be jumping
around time and space doctor who style working
with the time variants authority to clean up
alternate timelines that it seems like just
based on the trailer footage other versions of
loki have completely destroyed like all this
different footage makes it seem like the earth
is in shambles in all these different timelines
then you see female loki in one instance amidst
all this destruction and then in another one you
see president loki getting decked by this huge
dude while the main loki from the time variance
authority in the jacket is in the background
like rick and morty meets the marvel cinematic
universe only instead of rick sanchez it's many
versions of loki some worse than others they
also had their own version of the time variance
authority on that show they're just called the
time police they're played by key and peele if you
haven't seen any of those episodes get over here
but the loki series is one of the first marvel
phase four disney plus series that is getting
a season two no idea when that will release but
probably sometime after thor 4 love and thunder
so you can kind of see what's going on here we
don't really know how the loki season 1 will end
but early theory it's most likely that they set
up this loki for some kind of thor 4 teaser to
explain how he jumps to new asgard during the
original mcu timeline because he's traveling
between many different timelines during the loki
episodes and during thor 4 because he's already
been on his own path of redemption he's able to
help thor defeat gore the god butcher along with
the other characters then whatever happens at the
end of thor 4 he winds up returning to the work of
the time variants authority in the events of loki
season 2. even during the loki trailer when he's
jumping out the back of the plane doing that big
db cooper scene with the money flying out he calls
out to heimdall and brother thor so we know that
they're going to be characters on the loki series
just to explain what's going on with sif
because the reason why siff would cameo in
the movie is mostly because she was part of a
deleted subplot in thor ragnarok that was meant
to address what happens to the warriors three
characters originally what they were going to
do is they were going to have hela come to asgard
after she dispatches thor and loki and when she
arrives through the bifrost then she faces all
the asgardians the combined warriors 3 and sif
were also going to be there waiting to fight her
inhella was then supposed to destroy all of them
basically they were killing off the warriors 3
and all those characters including sif's character
jamie alexander had a scheduling conflict
with the movie and couldn't do the scenes
and then eventually taikawati kind of winnowed
the scene down and it wound up being one of the
warriors three so that's why sif isn't dead
right now but the warriors three themselves
technically are still supposed to be dead before
thanos showed up to take the space stone and kill
half the other asgardians including the original
loki because they already changed their plans so
much for sif it's possible that she doesn't wind
up getting killed by gore during the movie or she
could just wind up being another sacrifice jamie
alexander hasn't really said much about what she's
doing in the film matt damon's loki is one of
the few ones that i'm definitely expecting to
get slaughtered for the sake of comedy and if you
think about it christian bale and matt damon did
that 4v ferrari film together so it's kind of a
reunion for them valkyrie is still supposed to
be queen of asgard at the beginning of the film
we're supposed to get a much better look at the
entirety of new asgard they'll have built it out
quite a bit more taco batiti showed off a bunch of
concept art like you can see it here they're still
primarily a fishing economy like they're still
doing the same types of work as they were doing
during avengers end game but you see they built
this giant main hall here which is probably where
valkyrie spends most of her time there's a bunch
more births out back everything looks much shinier
much more sophisticated it's just a much better
version that they built out of new asgard since
the events of avengers endgame i've already talked
about all the guardians of the galaxy being in the
movie too the connection is all because of that
avengers endgame ending scene thor is with them
at the end of that movie so they have to address
what he's been doing this whole time losing all
that weight because he won't be fat thor but also
gore the god butcher would want to kill star-lord
because technically he is another god in the
marvel cinematic universe and it's something that
star-lord has boasted about before but talk about
funny deleted scenes in cameos if you haven't seen
all the deleted scenes from thor ragnarok there is
a deleted scene that they did on the fly on the
day because yondu was just there shooting scenes
for guardians of the galaxy and happened to be
walking across the lot they wound up filming
this scene of yondu coming to asgard while hella
was busy getting ready to execute more asgardians
hey hey stop it hold on
right there easy does it hoss
wait a minute
is i you know where kevin and lou's offices
are y'all oh thanks man then go ahead proceed
when he shows up there asking where lou's office
is and they point him off in another direction
and he just walks off on his way he's looking
for louis de esposito he's basically the other
mega producer who kind of runs marvel studios with
kevin feige he was just there for a normal meeting
and happened to be in his costume because they
were also filming some guardians of the galaxy
scenes nearby when this was happening in terms
of cameos and characters the only big ones from
thor ragnarok that we don't know about yet though
is the hulk mark ruffalo hasn't had time to spoil
any potential involvement in thor 4 but there
are a bunch of reasons why it would make sense
for him to not be in the film they've already
confirmed that they have big plans for hulk and
the abomination getting a big rematch during the
she-hulk series that's right they're bringing the
abomination back for that i'll talk more about
what's going on with him and the hulk videos
that i do when we learn more about the series but
the way kevin feige explains it because he says
the abomination has always been around they're
just waiting for an opportunity to bring him back
is that pretty much any major marvel villain that
isn't confirmed dead by one of the directors or
kevin feige is basically chilling out in the raft
that's where thunderbolt ross locks up all their
biggest villains i'm hoping that they pay that
off during an eventual thunderbolt series so
we'll see what they do with the abomination during
the she-hulk series but there's also a rumor that
they're going to have daredevil and jessica jones
cameos during that because she's also a lawyer
jessica walters just like daredevil and it's going
to take place around new york city everyone let
me know in the comments though which other
characters do you think that gore the god
butcher is going to wind up killing from the mcu
during thor 4. i mean you have to let him kill a
couple people otherwise he's not that threatening
but what'll happen is i have some new Wandavision
videos that i'm working on my Wandavision episode
3 video will also post on friday just like normal
so make sure you have alerts turned on for my
channel so you don't miss any of that there's a
whole bunch of spider-man stuff happening right
now click here for all those new spider-man 3
scenes and footage that just dropped and click
here for my Wandavision episode 1 in episode 2
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!